Speaker 1: Let's go next to Casey
from Kansas. Casey, welcome.
Speaker 3: Howdy.
Speaker 1: How are you?
Speaker 5: I'm assuming everybody
has already asked abortion questions.
Speaker 1: There have been a number of them.
Speaker 5: But mine is just more about the
the Democrats response to this. Do you fear
that the moderate Democrats will be too weak
to fight for abortion rights in this case?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, to some degree,
I think I haven't. To be perfectly frank, I
haven't paid much attention to the moderate
Democrat response so far, but it wouldn't surprise
me to see moderate Democrats. I mean, listen, they
can they can probably sort of not anger anybody
too much to jeopardize their positions by saying,
I am for choice, but want to leave it up
to the states. That's the kind of copout,
centrist statement they can make.
Speaker 5:
Okay. And just one more thing. Do you think
that the the Democrats response to the
extremist Supreme Court has been a failure
until now, the way that they have, like
not allowed rhetoric about how dangerous the
Supreme Court is with the extremists and and
completely not allowed discussion
about packing the courts or anything?
Speaker 1: I would say yes, but it's even bigger
than that. It's even back to 2016. Not enough
Democrats and people on the left saying this is
exactly what might happen if Trump beats Hillary.
I was saying it and I'm not patting myself on the
back because there were others saying it as well.
Speaker 5: But Jimmy Poor and Sam Seder.
Speaker 1: I don't remember Sam Sam taking
that position. I remember Dorsey taking it.
Speaker 5: He he had a debate with Jimmy Dore.
Speaker 1: All women said I don't
think was in agreement with me. Right.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. No,
it's this has been a problem for a while and
you're identifying one element of the problem,
but it's an even bigger problem.
Speaker 5:
Okay. Okay. Well, thanks for taking my question.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much for the
call. I appreciate that. Let's go next to Miguel.
From the country of Peru. Miguel, bienvenido.
Speaker 3: Could I have died? How you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well now. You're not on
a on a on a speakerphone, are
you? You would never do that.
Speaker 3: I would never do it. I have
headphones on right now. Beautiful. Great.
A lot of conversations about empanadas. I think
Peru has a lot to contribute to the conversation.
But I am for a reason. But I will ask a more
substantive question before we talk about that,
please. So about inflation. It's a big issue
not only in the U.S. but all over the world.
And I've had a lot of conversations about
if CPI or percentage change of CPI, which
is how we measure inflation, is really the best
way to reflect the increase of cost of living,
especially between different socio demographic
groups. So my question to you would be is there
a better way or anything that has been proposed
to understand the cost, the increase in cost
of living in different sociodemographic groups?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, you're absolutely correct
that CPI, meaning the Consumer Price Index,
which is often how we look at inflation, does
not capture every situation and every population
equally. If I understand correctly, it's mostly
urban centers and they're looking at food and
beverages, housing, apparel, transportation,
medical care, recreation. You know, it's a it's
a bunch of different things. You're completely
right. It's not perfect. And it doesn't capture
maybe at low middle and higher incomes what the
change has been. And of course, the other thing to
remember is that for lower incomes, a 5% increase
is much more meaningful than a 5% increase at
higher incomes. So no metric is perfect. And
I mean, I think the issue would be, okay, so
let's propose something else and I'm not sure
what that would be, but it's not a perfect metric.
Speaker 3: Agreed. Agreed. I have a quick another
question. I'm half-Jewish, but I'm not very
connected with with that part of my heritage.
What would be some Jewish foods and in particular
are Jewish foods in the U.S., mostly Eastern
European? Because I kind of feel like that's
kind of what's going on when I eat Jewish food
in the US. Is there American Jewish food versus
Eastern European Jewish food versus Middle Eastern
Jewish food? What does that look like?
Speaker 1: I don't I can't say too much
about American Jewish food, but basically when
people are talking about so-called Jewish food,
you've got the Eastern European stuff, which has
a lot of overlap with Russian and Ukrainian and
Polish food as well. And then you have what we
would consider more the Israeli foods, which
have a lot of overlap with other Middle Eastern
countries. So, you know, in your Eastern European
kind of area, you've got your matzo ball soup. Of
course, you've got pastrami on rye with mustard,
you have knishes. You know, you have kind of
like that world chocolate babka, things like
this on your Middle Eastern, more Israeli type
Mediterranean side. There's a lot of overlap with
other Middle Eastern countries, even a little bit
with places like Greece, etc.. And so there you're
talking about falafel or falafel, as some like
to say, stuff like that. I don't know about like
American Jewish food. I think it's just a kind
of either of the two things I just mentioned.
Speaker 5: Right. I was just thinking about.
Speaker 3: Pastrami sandwiches when like
a Jewish diner kind of thing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess that
is more American. So. So I guess I'll go back.
Like, the idea of brisket is more of an Eastern
European thing because it used to be really
cheap and you know, it wasn't very good and
you had to cook it all day for it to be remotely
tender. Now, brisket is is is very hip. But I
think if we talk about, you know, places like
Katz Deli in New York, that would be more the
Americanized Eastern European Jewish food.
Speaker 3: Great pleasure talking to you.